good morning John today I'm gonna
introduce you to some maps 40 to match
that helped me understand the world and
my place in it maps are an amazing kind
of art they tend to represent reality
but they don't have to it can put lots
of information into perspective they can
be extremely information dense and I
love information density which is why I
cut all the breaths out of my videos
historical maps don't just tell you
about the world they tell you about the
world that they were created during
which is really amazing and not just
what the world looked like back then but
also how little we knew about the world
back then what I'm reading Game of
Thrones I'm always super frustrated
because they haven't mapped the whole
world yet and I'm like if you go west
from Westeros what's over there it's
just amazing to realize that the
majority of people who lived in the
world Zophar didn't know what the whole
world looked like that just it seems
terrifying to me but once we had the
global maps we started using them for
more than just representing the world so
you could navigate it or divide it up
into things that were owned by different
people in country it's be given
interesting and useful way to display
and understand data about the world
population probably being the most
obvious example here's the world split
up into seven different regions each
with about 1 billion people and yes that
is north and south america and australia
just making up one of them australia is
mostly empty only 2% of people live in
the highlighted area inside the circle
there are more people living then
outside of that circle actually it's
this circle because things get distorted
when you take a globe and unwrap it into
a flat rectangular map which is why this
weird curvy line is actually the longest
straight line you can sail without
running into land there it is actually
projected onto a globe see straight line
the sailing route is only possible of
course because the earth is mostly water
which becomes more evident when you look
at the places that you could actually
make an earth sandwich I wish I mean
that there is actually land on both
sides of the planet in those places maps
can also show preferences of course for
alcoholic drinks for sides of the road
for how to pronounce caramel or caramel
or what to call call a soda pop cokes or
systems of measurement and yes the u.s.
is lagging a little bit behind the
metric system they're also in maternity
leave also in executing juveniles a
little embarrassing world mapper is an
amazing website and software tool that
distorts the world based on data because
really is the amount of land a country
has the most important thing about that
entry of course it's not here the world
is morphing from a map that shows the
amount of land that each country has to
the amount of people that each country
has while in this world mapper map we
see the number of Internet users
swelling from 2000 to 2007 these moving
maps that stretch to the dimension of
time or some of my favorites for example
this one that shows Internet usage over
24-hour period and this one that shows
global flights over a 24-hour period
whoa how as much as maps can help us
understand the world they can also
distort our perceptions of the world for
example the Mercator map projection
which we often use stretches out the
world at the poles in this map Africa
looks like it's about the size of
Greenland but in fact Africa is big very
big a continent of Africa is bigger than
the United States France Germany Spain
the UK all of Eastern Europe China and
India what also North being up is
completely arbitrary and it's kind of
convenient it turns out because most
people actually do live in the northern
hemisphere Western world we started out
with North being up with Ptolemy but
then we switched so that East was up so
that when you said to orient to orient
your map you were pointing toward the
Orient we switch back to the North being
on top because we got obsessed with the
Greeks during the Renaissance if you're
wondering we live in a big complicated
world sometimes wonderful sometimes
terrible always impossible to understand
completely the people who use these data
and these tools to make these
constructions of reality so that we can
better understand our world are some of
the heroes of the modern age adds off to
them and to our ever changing wonderful
world John I'll see you on Tuesday